ANATOLY SPITKOVSKY:
Well, I think
the Jacobus prize
is very special
because it recognizes a
particularly high achievement.
And there are so few
of them given out.
And it's a big honor.
ALEXANDER "SASHA" PHILIPPOV:
My name is Sasha Philippov.
I am a fifth-year
graduate student
in the Department of
Astrophysical Sciences working
on understanding how neutron
stars work, in particular how
pulsars produce their
electromagnetic radiation.
ANATOLY SPITKOVSKY: Sasha's
work has stood out to me
because he has
been able to solve
a very important and difficult
problem in astrophysics.
It's a problem about
understanding how pulsars work.
So pulsars are rotating
neutron stars --
very strongly magnetized,
very compact stars,
10 kilometers in radius
spinning very, very fast.
SASHA PHILIPPOV:
The frequency
at which you hear the bits
is the frequency of pulsar's
rotation.
So it rotates.
And once per period
it emits this burst.
And you see the
voice. Boom, boom.
And the clock is very steady.
So, over many years,
the thing rotates.
And the frequency at
which it emits radiation
is mostly constant.
ANATOLY SPITKOVSKY:
They've been known
to astronomers since 1967.
And they're emitting a lot
of interesting radiation.
They're emitting radio waves.
They're emitting gamma rays.
And, for a long time,
people couldn't understand
how they actually do this.
So what is going on
inside of these stars
and outside of these stars
in their magnetospheres?
So Sasha was able to
find a numerical solution
to this problem by putting
equations of plasma physics
on a computer and solving
this problem using
large, three-dimensional
simulations.
So he's been able to
achieve this breakthrough
in our understanding of how
these magnetospheres work.
SASHA PHILIPPOV:
I think, like,
science is driven mostly
by people's curiosity.
So it's just exotic.
It's hard to understand.
And that's what drives
people curious about them,
at least for me.
[MUSIC PLAYING]